let's go right ahead and speak to one of
the loudest voices fighting against the
brexit type Ken Clarke joins us now from
Nottingham Mr Clarke a very good morning
to you good morning let's dive straight
on and with brexit and the negotiations
at the moment appear to have stalled for
one reason the financial settlement
rather than us getting together with
Brussels and trying to get to grips with
a number that suits both sides it
appears our strategy has changed
somewhat and we are now arguing that
there is no legal obligation for us to
pay anything what do you make of that
well I think the concentration on the
money is because a large parts of the
media I mean of course this very
respectable program think it's the only
bit of the thing that they can interest
their readers in I think the and the
average member of the public is very
switched off with all the details about
single markets and customs unions tariff
barriers things which weren't talks
about at all during the referendum
campaign it's quite easy to get people
excited when you say they're gonna have
to the government's going to pay money
to foreigners after all they were told
that 350 million pounds a week was going
to be spent on the health service once
you stop paying any money to Brussels
and that everybody knows that if you are
going to have access to the market
you're gonna have to pay some of the
costs of that and the central Eastern
European so we'll expect regional funds
to help them one day become more
competitive with the French the German
and the British and if the British want
to be part of that they'll have prepared
contribution and there are all sorts of
things we've be signed up to we've their
budgets which we signed up to things we
will benefit from and it's just a
question of how much now that's a fairly
good question that's a fairly big
question there isn't it I mean that the
brexit bulldog himself David Davis at
writing in The Sunday Telegraph this
morning says this with the negotiations
delivering steady progress on issues
like citizens rights and Ireland that
this is not a moment to go backwards no
mention of the financial settlement it
appears what a country mile away from
that well the financial settlement is
important but if you announce it now we
all know that everybody on the right of
British politics will say is outrageous
support
although particularly all the real
skeptic newspapers will say this is
absolutely shocking and disgraceful and
everybody aside will start explaining
what our legal and moral obligations are
and what benefits we get in return for
it now I quite understand I think the
British government wants to leave all
that until we've got a little much
further on with the big substantial
issues the sum of money is not ruinous
the British economy it's not out of line
with what we've been paying for the last
several decades and I think it's the EU
is going to insist there's some
agreements on how eventually it's going
to be calculated what is in what is out
what is the basis of working out how
much I understand why David wants to
sort of draw a line there and get on
with other things otherwise the whole
debate in Britain will get comically
dominated by arguments about how
outrageous it is that we should pay a
penny it's it's like the constant debate
we have tried to defend overseas aid
which is very well spent money but it's
quite easy for a populace to tell
somebody why as British taxpayers money
spent abroad why isn't it being given to
you or spent on your public services
given all of that and giving you a good
your opposition to brexit itself let's
see I mean I wonder what you make of the
comments from the former Prime Minister
Tony Blair this morning that we can help
hold on to single market membership that
we can enjoy all those benefits we can't
stay inside the European Union all it
takes is a few domestic law changes when
it comes to immigration and of course
the European Union to do the same what
do you think well I'm pessimistic about
staying in the European Union I think I
bet Parliament voted by an enormous
majority to be bound by this referendum
I think myself is inevitable we are
going to leave the European Union what
matters now is how to keep as much of
the benefits we've had for the last 40
years I mean this has been the basis of
our relationship with most of the
countries and the rest of the world that
we're one of the leading influential
players in the EU and it certainly
played a big part in the combative
prosperity there on the whole for most
of those years rising living standards
in this country now Tony still thinks we
can stay in the EU I I think
the mood in the country it's hopeless to
expect that what we now need to address
is the practical consequences what's a
new relationship and the idea I mean the
single market and the customs union are
simply mean we don't start putting new
barriers between ourselves and our
biggest single market and the main
attraction for investment and so on and
I think that that we probably can
achieve it is quite important and I say
that most of the public I mean I hope
none of our viewers yet their eyes glaze
over once you talk about this but the
fact is that the easiest way of
explaining it I think is there's
absolutely no point in a free trading
country really dependent on trade
putting new barriers just satisfy a
political movement at new barriers
between trade and investment and driving
away foreign investors as a result hits
our economy very badly it's a long
transition deal yeah it's a long
transition period but we're running out
of time to do this Jeremy brown was
after you which I don't agree any of
this but in 1990 we are not going to
agree any of this by 1990 that's why we
need a long transitional period interim
period whatever you require that that's
that's inevitable otherwise the idea
that you jump off the cliff and then put
out your arms and you soar off into
those wide blue skies is it younger with
everybody in the world rushing forward
to open up their markets to in trade
deals that's all rubbish we obviously
need and everybody's accepting and
ministers are quietly anything that we
need a transition period that means two
three four years in which we stay
essentially with the status quo so as
far as business and industry is
concerned and in mr. Clark that there
are others within your party including
the Ian Duncan Smith in a number of
others who make the point that if you
want to have a transitional agreement
you need to know to what you are
transitioning ultimately it looks like
phase one discussions will not be
we will not have agreed that we've made
sufficient progress in October that
means it will be December before we do
it which means negotiations on trade and
on transition starts in January that
gives us ten months to sort out all the
detail can it be done no not remotely
that's sensible to believe we can be
done what wait on transition to is as
the government makes quite clear we hope
a free trade agreement with the European
Union in which we're not a member
we're a third party country outside
we've got satisfactory arrangement to
carry on trading with them which has
been done by other countries done by
Canada been done my Norway been done by
Switzerland and the Prime Minister
Teresa keeps saying she wants a
different one a special one for Britain
well as can take a lot of discussion it
is hugely complicated and what you can't
do is say well unless we know exactly
where we're going to we're suddenly
going to put tariff barriers regulatory
barriers have new customs procedures
with our borders and we're not going to
have you know people coming to work here
in the health service anymore that would
be utterly lunatic because of this
deadline in 1990 2019 that's why do I
talk about its deadline in 2019 which
you know it's simply not enough time mr.
Koch before we get there for the gangs
now we get what we invoke Mr Clarke I
just want to leave us on slightly mean
before we get into all of that before
you mean reach that point we have the
small matter of the second reading of
the EU withdrawal bill now you and a
number of others of raised concerns
about the Henry the eighth Clause is
this power grab nominal power grab a
supported paragraph by the government
and how are you minded to vote tomorrow
well it depends that it's a government I
think he's going to have to change the
wording of the bill I mean the basic
point to make all the European
regulations British regulations needs a
bill so that they need they say they
should have brought forward one that's
properly drafted but a government that
started by saying he didn't want
Parliament to have anything to do with
this it was going to use the Royal
Prerogative
and we weren't even I have a vote on
article 50 he has somehow in
the draftsman to produce a bill which
would give Henry the eighth power switch
he would have you know been delighted by
and just in case they need them they've
given us a sweeping pass to put in place
whatever Arrangements they want on any
subject to actually decide how much
money we give to the Europeans without
Parliament having a votes on it this is
ridiculous
if they come back tomorrow and say of
course they're going to amend it they
that we've been reassured they're not
going to use these powers in any
policymaking way at all well I think
Parliament will be sensible to get them
to write it so they're not giving
themselves the possibility of using
powers that no governments ever tried to
take at the expense of Parliament before
then we hear a lot of the substance
which is all this about you know are any
rules going to be changed in such a way
that we get in the way of our trade with
Europe or changes our arrangements with
Europe in any other way which the
government seems to be saying on the
whole no it's not discussion of politics
these days we're never far away from
comments about the at the conservative
leadership Jacob Riis smoked perhaps
damaged his chances this week with some
choice words on on abortion and given
the party's direction on the European
Union given the words of mr. Reece morg
I just wonder would a young Ken Clark
naturally gravitate towards the
conservative well I joined the
modernizers in the Conservative Party at
a time when we were campaigning for
Britain to join the European Union
there's an irony about my career in my
first Parliament joined the European
community is benefited I think for the
40 odd years that I've been in politics
my last Parliament we're deciding to
leave it for a lot of silly populist
reasons but as you say everybody turns
to the leadership when the Conservative
Party can't think of anything else to do
intends to have a leadership crisis when
it's rather puzzled by policies and the
reason is I mean I'm quite aware of the
fact that the things we've been talking
about in this in this interview they're
complicated
they're quite difficult they compare
they concern investors and trade union
leaders and businessmen more than the
ordinary member of the public the the
euro skeptic campaigners offered
simplicity this dangerous changing world
all these foreigners living here now all
brussels fault leave the EU one bound
we're free and a brave new world will
emerge
well that is nonsense and it's no good
diverting ourselves by saying would
Jacob Riis mob be a 21st century prime
minister which I suspect Jacob thinks
it's rather a silly question certainly
at this stage of his career
I'm afraid the government has to be
given as mainly the powers required to
manage your transition we've got many
years of complicated negotiations in
front of us our economy is a very
worrying state I mean we have slowed it
down very badly in the outlook is very
uncertain we need as soon as possible
and assurance that economically and in
trade terms I arrange the receive Europe
again a carry on for some years as they
are now so that this can all be sorted
out sensibly it's our children and our
grandchildren we should be thinking
about not next week's newspaper
headlines and can we have fun with the
kind of Strictly Come Dancing type
contest between people who want to be
Prime Minister Theresa May is there
there's no prospect of being replaced by
anybody sensible in any sensible process
the next two or three years Tory's got
the job of presiding over a smooth
transition through a long transition
period to an arrangement that at least
will minimize the damage in a few years
time Ken Clark I'm afraid we're gonna
have to leave it there and I did even
have a question about you whether or not
you'd consider an appearance on Strictly
Come Dancing at some stage after your
parliamentary clear believe that we'll
leave that for the next digit certainly
not the bake-off and i standing in
leadership relationship standing in
leadership relations is the only bad
habit I've ever given up Ken Clark
thanks very much for being with us